[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris weber nba on tnt analyst
he was on the call for the bucks and the
nets last night on tnt next game lakers
bucks thursday
night at 7 30 eastern also on tnt
oh look at you mr milwaukee buck with
your milwaukee bucks t-shirt on did you
pay for that
no okay i got so many uh i could wear
all the teams i was
i guess i was i used to say i wasn't
superstitious but i would never wear
other teams now
i i take all the swag they give me i
work out in it so
were the pistons your favorite team
growing up
yeah by far it was uh the pistons and
then
uh i it was the pistons and the lakers
magic being from michigan
and then i hated chicago and
uh the celtics so much that i really
loved
secretly so it was a
tango web back there well why did you
hate boston
well remember you know back then you had
to go through certain teams so back then
the pistons had to go through boston so
you know
i grew up hating dick stockton because
every time his voice came on it reminded
me of the celtics games you know you
think the commentators have something to
do with the game
and so remember is there turning it over
that's a crazy story well we got
whoopings that night because we went
crazy running through the house
and isaiah turned it over and then we
beat the celtics got through them
you know that's when you see kevin
mchale giving isaiah the pound tell him
you better go win it you better go win
it
isaiah hurts himself and i guess 44 in
the finals
we lose to the lakers good job magic and
then we beat them
the next two so i hated the celtics
because we had to go through them and of
course
just the bulls just because okay but
what was that like when you're watching
isaiah throw the ball in just get the
ball in
and you're going to beat the celtics and
larry bird slowest guy on the floor
comes out of nowhere and steals the ball
hits dj for the layup
it was crazy when i went when i played
the celtics the first time i remember
having like
spree and those guys pick me up and
seriously like i know
kyrie takes the um sage and does that
around but i really thought it had to be
like a leprechaun on top of those rims i
really thought back then it was
something with the parquet floor that it
was
magic and so i just felt like wow come
on out of out of all you know
the times that this could happen so that
that was one of the worst moments
for me as a basketball fan were you a
lions fan too growing up
yeah wow wow i remember going to a
friend's wedding and
uh all these uh lions uh
you know we were there and so yeah it
was uh
i was i was a big lions fan still now
you know billy sims
and you know other players that we've
had during that time even though we're
most famously known for being the only
team
uh where two hall of famers general
generations of talents retire early
rather than
calvin johnson and barry sanders they
decided you know what i'd rather not
play
instead of playing with the lions i'd
rather not play at all yeah but
you know what i'm i'll be quick but i'm
a cleve i'm so i'm a lions fan still to
this day
but in 99 i think it was the year
cleveland got their team back yeah
uh i was just mad at the lions i don't
know if we were going on 16 then or
whatever but
i'm just a frustrated fan i think they
take our love for granted
but anyway i became a cleveland browns
fan that day as my second team because i
couldn't just jump on a bandwagon
so it's fun watching them do it you know
what they did this year
he's c webb and he was on the call with
the bucks and nets
last night what are the nets doing so
far
with out kyrie with with uh james and
katie that surprised you
it doesn't surpr nothing surprised me uh
with this team
dan um you know i think 50 things can be
true at one time you know
uh hard left unceremoniously he got uh
he gained weight he did all those
things but he's still one of the best
players
and i still believe d'antoni is
responsible
for how hard and played there d'antoni
told me personally that
he believed that remember how you would
throw the ball in the shack shaq would
wait and throw it back out and maybe
that play took 15 seconds
he believed that hardin was doing that
from the top of the key as a post-up
player
and that okay dan if you're ready to
shoot okay we'll throw it back
now i'm going to dribble and find one of
you that's what he believed was this was
his post play i don't believe hardin
i believe he liked playing like that but
he can play so much more efficiently
and by those guys being friends i put a
lot of of it on mentality
but by those guys being friends i expect
them to share the ball and
i believe hard knows that durant is the
best player in the nba
and you know he defers uh at times so
do you think jordan's the best player in
the nba
i think he's the best
he'd have to be top two you know i know
that offensively
that it's no one in the game like him
that maybe that we've
maybe that we've ever seen and i think
his teammates know that
i think that durant learned how to play
a different style
um playing for coach kerr and with those
players
i think he learned to trust players
playing at golden state
meaning like if you're in the right
place just make the right play because
he just plays so much
more calm and effortlessly and so he
lets the game come to him so and nash is
their coach
you know i said this last night you know
dan
you may remember this so i don't want to
put words in your mouth but in my
opinion and i believe this with all my
heart
nash dribbled the ball more than harder
it was just
the way that he did it it was just he
dribbled in a circle all the way around
up under the basket but he would just
make great plays but he shouldn't
last though chris yeah
yeah he did but i'm not talking i'm not
talking about shooting i'm talking about
ball handling
and so i think that having a guy like
nash
because we used to want nas to shoot
more so that other guys wouldn't get
involved
so nash is brilliant i'm not criticizing
it i'm just saying that the game has
changed and nash is part of the reason
why
hardness successful and by the way
d'antoni is on that bench that coach
nash that way
and then vice versa and so i believe
that you know if this is their style of
play i believe
nash is a great guy to talk to harden
about how to do it
well i think with harden we look at it
as he just pounds the ball and then he's
going to take his shot
nash would dribble and you're right he
was almost like wayne gretzky gretzky
used to go behind the net
and then he would try to set up his
teammates nash was
a pass first and james is a
shoot first shoot second pass third and
i think people look at it and they don't
like
sort of he's a ball hog i don't think
people looked at nash as a ball hog
as much as they do james but i i still
say
why is it that harden can get 11 assists
but kyrie can't
like kyrie's not a great passer chris
you know when i played with allen
iverson a lot of people used to say that
uh
he was selfish and he definitely is
looking for his shot
that's the way alan was made
and programmed to be kyrie is so skilled
at scoring and getting to where he wants
and his size i think when you trap
prohibits now
should he be a better pastor should he
get more assist yes i agree with you and
i go back to nash
it's not about i don't want in any way
want to make nasty himself
he's one of the most selfless players
ever but
when you have two guys on the side of
you you have to trust them and and
i've seen harden do that when he led
their team and assists when he was the
third guy coming off with he and
westbrook
so i trust their relationship and when
you play with greats
you feel like okay i can get mine is
what is the question
i do think is kyrie and kenny fit
can he get others involved but if you
have hardened at the point guard
why can't kyrie be the two offensively
meaning
because i agree dan he should get more
six so i agree with you but if he's not
going to why wouldn't you let them get
that same amount
and just do it from a two position and
score and then keep the ball in harden's
hands
yeah he's he's this enigma he's a
fascinating guy and you were on the set
with uncle drew so you spent time with
him like do you
even though you spent time with him do
you understand do you do you know kyrie
irving or feel like you do
no i don't i don't know kyrie no i don't
know
i don't i don't know him at all um i
know his
father a little bit through friends of
mine like rod strickland and others i
know his father was a heck of a hooper
and a great
great man um but i don't and and i think
because i'm in a movie people think that
i can give
insight you know i i don't this is a
different generation this is a different
day and so my thing is
you know as a commentator to hold him
accountable
and then to balance it with the things i
don't know and so that's why like so in
my day
i could only say this then in my day if
i would have played in washington i
wanted to play with
spree well i wanted them to trade him
for caliber chain straight up
what's up coward i love it but
i played and at that time i knew the
spree
spent on being jordan defensively
i mean this guy was incredible he was a
friend but he was incredible and i
remember going i want to play with him
and i know
that if i were to play with him i would
have played better whether i had more
shots or less shots i know that
you know whatever the situation and no
disrespect to calbert i just meant
because of our relationship i think
friends
hold each other to a higher standard
depending on what type of friends you
have
i think durant does is that is the alpha
male in the situation
and i believe that they had to talk to
each other about it and so if you as
friends get in the room and you talk
about it
make a commitment say we're going to win
you know make a toast have a drunk talk
oh buddy we're going to do it
you got to stick to it and no coaching
can make you sacrifice no friends no
family it's the commitment you made to
each other
and that's the only thing that i rely on
that's
that's why i think kg worked when he got
to boston that's why i think
rasheed worked when he got to detroit
and many people didn't think it would
but they didn't know the personal
relationships and so then that's all i
can put it on because i don't know kyrie
at all would you want to play
with kyrie
would i want to play if if i could play
today and be healthy
and and go back in time and play today
with
who i was i would yes i would want to
play with him because i was a
pick-and-roll player and as long as you
give me the ball off the pick-and-roll
i i could do you know whatever i need to
do you might not give me that
off the pick-and-roll well you know
very very honest if i could play today
you know or if i could play in my
lifetime the three guys i would have
want to play with uh
probably magic nash and lebron
uh because i was a big guy and those
guys those guys sponsored
no jordan
of course i'd love to play with jordan i
just meant you know you're going to
touch the ball a lot with joe knowledge
you would have been you would have been
horace grant
yeah exactly exactly but hey always got
some rings so yeah i wouldn't mind that
yeah you might have been will purdue i
don't know but um uh you know
i i was watching the lakers last night
they're up 14 in the fourth quarter now
i know it's a game in january here chris
how do you blow a 14 point lead against
golden state
at home because golden state uh
golden state has a chip on his shoulder
i think from
kerr enjoying coaching probably more
than ever
um to curry coming back i mean you see
the shots that curry wants you know guys
what i really love the guys are really
humble off the court but their alter
egos are on the court and curry is a
little jerk
on the court he's the
[Laughter]
like sick seventh grade needs to play
tag in all the games the little fellas
always won because you couldn't catch
him and you were just mad and that's
curry he's shooting threes he's getting
other guys going
draymond i mean it's a time for them to
really show who they
are in the midst of this and so it
didn't surprise me
it really didn't surprise me that golden
state did that it would surprise me if
other teens but
when you have curry and those boys man
you just you better bring your hard hat
every night but
could curry act this way back when you
played
no no
i i i just remember you know karma long
i think 22 stitches to isaiah i just
remember you know oakley
other guys it was just a it was just a
different day i mean
um you know i i had to change the way
i acted after you know
two or three seasons because it's just
not worth it you know i mean
you know cummings has nothing to lose
there's two years left in his career
and he's on the bench why why try to
three six down the left
wait who do you still owe something to
as far as what do you mean they did
something to you
but you didn't want to lose game checks
and get back at them
do you have a grudge towards anybody
no i would say though that that that
terry cummings is the one
is the one loss that i took you know i
wanted to fight xavier mcdaniel i wanted
to you know back then it was
wwf
chris exactly
so how about this you know your
grandfather you ever see your
grandfather get mad and give you that
look and he doesn't say anything yeah
and you get more skin that he's a
minister and it's like oh my god he made
a commitment to god
[Laughter]
so that was my rookie year he pulled me
out the air
gently but he grabbed me and he wouldn't
let me go and he said no
don't don't do that anymore and uh billy
and those guys they didn't come up
and like you know talk they were they
looked at him like no he's the crazy one
that's what i learned never fight a guy
that cries
before the fight and then guys that are
real calm like him just
just leave him alone wait the guys who
cry before the fight
oh oh you never oh damn never fight a
guy
that starts crying before a fight wait
who started crying before a fight
i've seen it before i bet some people
out there have seen it before
calling let dan know like didn't um
didn't linux lewis lose to a guy was
that mccall
crying before a fight it was all over
oliver mccall
yeah he started crying but yeah i've
seen i've seen bullies get knocked out
maybe two in my lifetime when uh the guy
getting bullied just started crying
that's when you just know he has nothing
to lose
you don't want to fight a guy with
nothing but but you know like charles
oakley wouldn't start crying before he
would
pummel somebody he might just start
smacking him
terry cummings is a minister that that's
what i
i find amazing that he's supposed to be
a god-fearing peaceful man chris
yeah i would i would i would tell his
congregation
you better behave you better donate
money put it in the collection plate
there
or um hey great to catch up
as always we appreciate you uh your
stories is and chris will be on the
bucks lakers call thursday night 7 30
eastern on
tnt see webb always great to catch up
thank you very much
thanks for having me hi brother